[Music]
welcome to Jhansi with the stars the
magical world of Disney came to life on
the ballroom floor Monday Heather Morris
channeled her inner princess onna from
frozen with this jazz routine that
scored a 34 out of 40 but the best news
of all
Heather's getting her original partner
Maksim Chmerkovskiy back next week when
are you coming back Islands officially
fired I'm taking over as of tonight
Simone biles and Sasha Farber's Moana
themed contemporary dance was incredible
they even had the voice of Moana Aly ich
ravallo sing for them
[Music]
I actually felt amazing and beautiful I
felt like a Disney Princess like a
real-life you wanna other standout
numbers Bonner and Shauna's wreck-it
Ralph tango a far less emotional number
than last week there's not a prairie
dancer just thankful to be here that's
what I'm thinking like I'm alive and
dance at all nor money and vows fierce
Mulan themed Paso Doble earned a nearly
perfect score 39 out of 40 an
opportunity to do it again and hopefully
get a 10 this time a freshly shaven Nick
and his partner Peeta danced an adorable
routine to a Pinocchio classic I think
he really know that everybody loved a in
this we just knew we had a great routine
planned and we were both very excited
about this dance I'd love to sub outfit
on well you know gotta own it but
unfortunately the magic wore off for one
couple the couple leaving right now is
Erika and Glenn
[Music]
Oh